ager dinkle edge Yallah carpet ride
check out leoz I wonder what he's
dreaming about he is probably dreaming
about what we is gonna do to the team in
the West I wonder to various myths
peaking for sure I'm a bad man magenta
and an awful sport smoothly wireless you
can call me ty Royal wrapping up rushes
like aluminum foil between gold a very
scary
you best be wary the carpet Ron took
Mary I love the ball so much I want to
marry
[Music]
we are the best
I'm into Brahim boys soon my rhymes are
clean like my name was dr. Seuss shower
him that's my name
power candles sounds the same with Jack
Murray the Swale ready to borrows from
the mall dr. Watson played sax after
Marcus played guitar
[Music]
cuz ya'll a one-member this ozamataz
player
[Music]
Smith comma Daniel other kickin Selena
or the candle cheerleaders up am I
talking crotch who's got their baby
cocker spaniel BYU why you be back as
the bitch wanna get with me got swisher
Sweets and nuts he's wrong and um some
team Kentucky's hit and field girls
blunted been drunk when I planted been
like 100 times that I've already done it
Oh see these haters thought I was
playing staying away from our faces with
honor when you tossing those gauntlet
some Dan Smith and the West is getting
rowdy like lost
[Applause]
you